orléans nous partons avec deux des
trente pêcheurs professionnels encore en
activité sur la loire bruno et robert
ami passionné de pêche depuis l'enfance
ont accepté de faire pêche commune pour
nous narrer leurs expériences sur la
rivière oui rivière c'est comme ça qu'il
nomme la loire métier plutôt solitaire
aujourd'hui il l'était moins du temps
des grands filets barrages c'est immense
filet qui barrait le passage au saumon
poisson roi de la loire il y a deux
siècles ce migrateur s'est raréfiée car
la loire a changé le poisson aussi
l'arrêt des drags de sable dans les
années 90 a profondément modifié la
rivière moi j'ai vu arriver le centre
j'ai vu arriver de silures j'ai vu
arriver les aspects j'ai vu disparaître
les saumons les ennuis c'est une
évolution permanente en fait robert
pêche depuis 38 ans il a connu la vente
directe aux restaurateurs qui
consommaient leur carte en fonction de
l'arrivage bruno lui de formation
supérieure en gestion des espaces
naturels pêche professionnellement
depuis huit ans je n'ai pas connu la
pêche du saumon les anguilles disons en
quantité importante
et puis même la friture donc
la masse des poissons qui prônait c'est
du poisson lucie brunet du poisson blanc
cas nombreux arrêts dont aucun parent
difficile à commercialiser dans une
filière traditionnelle en restauration
donc c'est pour ça que je me suis mis à
me dis que je transforme au poisson
pourrait donner le pouvoir aux mails ma
pêche pour un pêcheur comme bruno qui
les transforme tout est bon là il ya
aucun problème tout est bon mais au
niveau pêche pur comme moi je fais c'est
très limité maintenant par exemple
maintenant la carte c'est difficile à
passer le silure est la mauvaise presse
alors qu'il est très bon silure c'est un
poisson en europe centrale donc été
méconnu quand il est arrivé mais à
savoir que c'est un poisson qui a la
carte de restaurant sur les bords du
danube
c'est un poisson qui a une chair assez
ferme donc et notamment sur la loire
parce que il résiste au courant on peut
le cuisiner un peu comme les poissons à
chair assez ferme
où
je suis pour celle d'avoir illégalement
depuis dix mois
alors ça ce sont des algues
filamenteuses qui se développe depuis
quelques années en loi dès que la loire
chooz ça se développe sur le fond
apparemment après ça se décrochent à se
promène partout dès 2005 les algues
filamenteuses prospère elle sans pêche
la pêche mais aussi l'installation des
poissons cette production végétale de
plus en plus importante est due à
plusieurs facteurs combinés
aujourd'hui on a on a un fleuve qui
qu'ils dégradent avec la ligue
filamenteuses simplement les tonneaux
minéraux dans le dans le dans loubès
d'assouan nitrates azote phosphate donc
on pourrait dire bah la loire allait
s'améliorant qualité un qualité ya moins
de minéraux dans l'eau simplement l'eau
est plus claire et il y en a encore
suffisamment pour que l'algue se
développe le biotope change le poisson
devient l'aliment de beaucoup de
prédateurs les oiseaux pêcheurs
prélèvent leur tribu comme le cormoran
qu'ils ingurgitent un demi kilo de
poisson par jour
il en est de même des populations
piscicoles avec de plus en plus de
poissons carnassiers dernière arrivée la
star actuellement donc il y avait un
nouveau poisson qui hélas peu qui
arrivait donc
poisson ni prix ni la même famille que
les cartes que les brèmes que les
cheveux mais lui qui devient carnassiers
à taille adulte
donc ça fait un poisson bien sûr qu'ils
s'attaquent à la friture
le silure on mange également on a
également parlé des cormorans donc ça
fait beaucoup de chose qui attaque
le début de la chaîne on sait pas de
quoi quoi va être fait
les dix prochaines années en tout cas la
loire elle en train de se changer de
paysage
on changeait radicalement donc à plein
de paramètres nouveaux donc il ya des
poissons ont sûrement s'adapter après
peut pas savoir l'évolution est
l'importante là depuis les dix dernières
années issu de la tradition est poussé
par l'avenir
les pêcheurs professionnels s'inscrit
dans une gestion durable
constamment sur le terrain ils sont les
premières sentinelle de l'évolution du
paysage ligérien